[Applaudissements]
fellow quiz on l'accueillera bien sûr
juste après ce que je le voie sinon ça
va partir en cacahuète attention lequel
des quatre jours propose des anecdotes à
votre avis qui a fait ça c'est un grand
jaloux et fouillent souvent le portable
de sa conjointe d'année médical des cats
vous dit dany brillant
philippe sont bien dany brillant c'est
dany brillant c'est danny ayalon avance
avant avant à mon ancienne conjointe
alors là je suis guéri parce qu'en fait
je me suis aperçu que le jaloux c'est
celui qui a pas confiance en lui bah
c'est ça et comme il n'a pas confiance
en lui n'a pas confiance en lui mais au
final nous est mélangé de la résidence
ou pas et comment au final vous avez
raison d'avoir confiance en l'autre
est-ce que vous avez découvert dans le
portable
pas grand chose un jeu et un beau de
faire ça à laval à 20 nokia 62,17 un jeu
de serpents il a pas de la trouvais ça
louche mais depuis votre nouvelle mais
maintenant j'ai travaillé sur la
confiance en moi a très bien et j'ai
confiance et ça va trouver le même temps
la nouvelle miss ne va pas dire qu'il
est en train de fouiller sur son
portable
moi je vous le dis je fous ils
voudraient portable de tout le monde
même dans l'équipe c'est vrai il était
là d'où